and privacy episodio è invece fatta una
cambiato la faccia faccio una gamba sola
non ci voglio credere perché ti allacci
le scarpe in questi momenti padre di uk
di merda e maria che dall arte kiero mi
amor fa vedere
quello è esageratamente j ax non lo vedi
che canta maria che dolore in gigante e
uil è che non te ne frega un cazzo
dell'intro è maledetto io che spreco se
se mettiamo insieme tutti i minuti che
ho passato nella mia vita a fare la
intro se non escono fuori delle giornate
intere di 24 ore l'una e nessuno se
rincula mai state quindi figuriamoci ai
ragazzi siamo dall'adisu è più in se
oggi siamo su sbuffi make come primo
livello bosso fa garriot altro
complimenti per il nome di lo fa anche
rima bosso fa gariglio complimenti per
il nuovo zio e o anche tre milioni e
mezzo di iscritti tutti i meritatissimi
santa
cos'è sta roba tui dirmi che un livello
dove c'è un [ __ ] frullatore è
arrivato buono buono sto frullato
guardaci medici aggiungo un po di me
stesso perché esattamente cagare
niente proprio e questo livello il primo
è immaginate negli altri come gatto su
un bel l'impossible 99 99 per cento dall
ufficio tv che crede di fottermi fa
vigentini in ma non ha capito che non è
un figo abbastanza però proviamoci
chi deve morire la madre però proviamo
cinismo ma porca eva lercia come ho
fatto a morire sono vivo e sto
scherzando e con una freccia conficcata
nel naso dall'alto secondo me si può
ancora sopravvivere credo è io non testo
non soffriamo le frecce ovunque prima o
poi come ho schivato gli arpioni signori
bassa basta io posso concludere qua è
più in stile goodbye 2016 che cazzo ha
fatto il livello parlando nuovo spiegami
ai botti di capodanno con nonno ciak
fantastico voi non lo sapete ragazzi ma
in realtà nei fuochi d'artificio
se non a chuck e fanno anche male quando
cadono lego rock swing di fatto un rock
swing coi lego zio quanto puoi star male
mi spieghi quanto stai male da 1 a
cerebroleso zio 9 non importa champagne
credono cosa che mi ha fatto male di te
porcaccia vacca non pensavo fosse una
corda con la roba lì era talmente grossa
che non penso fosse una corda siamo in
due adesso a giocare ragazzi però sono
vivo sono tutto bello in forma eccolo lì
la spaccata della vita e lisa fusco può
accompagnare solo perché siamo non
soltanto sto completando è perfetto la
barra non avevo dubbi
ok ragazzi unito in un pezzo unico
dovrei riuscirci in teoria crespi ero e
sono una tragedia come mi sono salvato
ma che culo avete presente l'essere
[ __ ] cosa significa questo significa
questo quando quando vi chiederanno cosa
significa essere un [ __ ] mettete
questo video indicate sia a me che lui
tutti e due
porcaccia le valerci nora lo rifaccio
vincolate non mi interessa che ti in cui
le punte di ferro va bene così felice è
c'ero anch'io choose your fatality j ax
spiegami j ax che cazzo vuol dire lo
svegliava spero di andare su j ax me ne
frega niente tanto ragazzi la so già
quale è inutile mela nascondono sarà
tipo o maria che dall arte kiero mi amor
fammi vedere
no
quello è esageratamente j ax non lo vedi
che canta maria che dolore in gigante se
per me i ragazzi j ax basta per tutte va
bene così 8 il philip green
secondo me i ragazzi riesco ad andare su
home ci metto un po ma secondo me ci
riescono andare fermi un attimo
ok non era esattamente quello che volevo
fare porca eva sentisse finiva tritata
bellissimo attenzione l'ultima in realtà
non sono capaci a fare il botto
però sto benissimo a mettere le cose
imparate una sull'altra questa cosa mi
esce benissimo 77,7 per cento impossible
spiegami che cazzo fa tipo che melo su
chi tutto kill your bones che sto qua è
un classico ragazzi questo è un classico
del male tra l'altro se riuscissi a non
l'avevo vista mai la mina a ho capito
fermi potere tavolo che è fortissimo o
del piede staccato anche quello è un
potere fortissimo chi vuole un piede
il regalo per natale visto che non
faccio regali o di solito che non so mai
cosa prendere a parte il niente mi
servirebbe capire se vi interessa un
piede perché se non mi stacco anche
l'altro vi regalo anche quello save e
timi che sarebbe look ma ancora non l'ha
capito
perfetto questo non significa salvare
team i ragazzi neanche questo porca eva
un lancio che sia un lancio un music
news un rock swing colorful pieno di
colori mamma mi ha fatto bene ed live
dei viola mi devi spiegare come giocare
che io gioco è primis prima che tu
nascessi do you see cosa non eletto ma
va bene stato ci sarà state scritte
cagate sicuro presa ferro ragazzo non mi
devi dare consigli io so tu non sai
giocare tuo livello meglio di quanto non
sappia giocare io e questo ne è la prova
elevator simulator 3 e che caselli de
vito simulator for champio è addirittura
un ascensore per campioni casa
l'ascensore della juventus del
barcellona ce li ha difficoltà perna b
ma perché ci vuole un genio
per salire un ascensore però vabbè ma
sono quelli ad ostacoli allora no
aspetti facciamolo serio facciamolo per
extreme vai vai zio ma io sono tutto
carico è bello vai frate su camila mi su
camila do ok ho iniziato tutto però
forse ci possono però fare forse già
passando da fare forse ce la faccio
sai versione a no di qua non si passa
bene non so fa sono scarsi se ora posso
fare via difficoltà estrema è ancora
superiore a quella per campioni
porcaccia vacca ce la posso fare dai ma
sentono la sentono sento me lo sento
forte
porca eva affatto difficile e va bene se
svecchiato tutto normale delle
sopracciglia frate però perfetto non
così porca eva c'è la fiom e ce l'ho
fatta
dove vado e vabbè nome mettetele in
calabria l'entrata prossimo lo dico è
ragazzi sto tizio secondo me vuole
pedate nel culo fortissime anzi è
diventato una foca ragazzi ce la devo
fare una sfida contro me stesso se non
ce la faccio non prosegue negli altri
livelli ce la posso fare
me lo sento 17 fortissimo [ __ ]
happy days spinning corse coca horse e
non sono inglese ragazzi non sono io e
vabbè tutti ubriachi perché a capodanno
ci sono andati troppo pesanti con la
vodka spinning l'assise ciao zio che sei
morto vabbè ci sono frate ci sono tutto
carico è fortissimo perfetto è non è
esattamente quello che intendevo ma
vabbè perché i tavoli di questi giorni
sono così crudeli cosa avete fatto ai
tavoli così male per farli incazzare
così tanto anche ai bidoni quanti
problemi con l'alcol e robben ops è
andato a sinistra non si può andare
peccato aveva risalto tutti forte perché
io non distrugge vidoni oli cavalco rand
5 spinning frutta che era la più facile
tra l'altro per ora ce la posso fare
sono rimasto un po maciullato uk è
passato a miglior vita ma va bene sono
contento di aver vinto bottle flip auto
a pensavo di lanciare un auto una
macchina a non lo fa da solo ma cosa
cose h ancora la basta
cazzo il fenomeno sono un fenomeno
quando sono stato bravo in questo
livello è tutto è tutta maestri o forse
un giorno potrete essere bravi come me
ma solo dopo tanto allenamento poco jump
2017 va ci mancava guardo solo questo
c'è già un livello che già che ci siamo
che nell'anno nuovo inauguriamo lo con
un happy with del 2017 anche se
effettivamente non cambia un cazzo dal
2012 che ci sosti livelli anzi forse
anche prima mlg 360 uno scopo quello
l'ho fatto a madre perché non c'ho
voglia sono passato ho preso tutto
vitasnella parte ii accade imposti volti
a mente non mi basta questa ora mi sto
già rotto il cazzo giocasta roba perché
se non ci arrivi col pensiero ci arrivi
con le braccia staccate fa vj 2017 vabbè
ai ragazzi proviamo l'ultimo in assoluto
da sassi nate trump va bene fammi capire
un attimo il senso di suo livello giusto
per capire perfetto ero io donald trump
a quelle quelli erano ok di bodyguard
specie di prova lezione salve donald i
capelli erano una menzogna
le ho provate a prendere tutto quello
che ti spetta la carica di presidente
degli stati uniti d'america è tua
non si muove a è scemo pavé ragazzi
concluso qui il bisogno di happy days
spero vi sia piaciuto anche perché
diventa sempre più strano sto gioco però
inutile che faccio questa affermazione
ogni volta lo dico ma tutto è sempre
così non cambia un cazzo è più mi va
bene come saluto mio più sull'argomento
è un mi piace a capace di facebook e
come descrizione dell'iniziativa ci
mettiamo proseguito bella ragazzi